[Music]
the next one is related to prayer and
this may be
dated i don't think it's too dated but
i'm reading a quote i think it's quote
from you which is i'm trying to write a
book on prayer for people who struggle
with prayer and i think most people do
at least the ones i know and then it
goes on to talk about other potential
books on forgiveness and so on
i would
love to know what
prayer
means to you
and if such a book would be for
religious people or if
a
version of prayer would be
made
available through such writing to people
who do not consider themselves religious
definitely the most personal question
anyone's ever asked me
tim but since we've been talking now for
almost two hours i feel like we're very
close
now i'm teasing of course but let me try
to answer that i am trying to write a
book on prayer and since i became
president of shalom college i was lucky
to finish wild problems i haven't made
any progress on that prayer book since i
got to israel it's kind of ironic
the holy land
but i think for people who aren't
religious and by the way i was not
religious my whole life so i had a
a part of my life where i was not
praying regularly and where i was not
keeping the jewish sabbath and where i
was eating lobster pork and enjoying it
immensely
and i think every not everyone it comes
back a little bit to the
comment i made earlier about being tone
deaf but most people i think
can experience the transcendent
or the a word that i find very difficult
to think about but i love the word it's
imminent not meaning soon but sort of
embodied in you imminent imm a-n-e-n-t
and in the book that i'm working on uh
someday maybe
i talk about the handful of times when
i've come into contact with that and i'm
sure you have two
example i use is i'm in california
we've taken the family my wife and i
have taken the kids to see it the
shakespeare production outside in uh in
santa cruz which is just really fun
you're in these redwoods and uh it's
it's just it's lovely
it's been a long day we've had a good
time as a family and
we're driving back and i think
everybody's asleep with the car except
me we're driving back to palo alto and
um
[Music]
i realize that to my left
it is such a dark night for some reason
and there's so little light pollution
that the stars are as vivid as they are
say in yosemite or
the negev the desert here in israel this
is the two places i've seen the best
stars of my life
and
they're luminous they're not just like
white dots they're they're luminous
and
you can see them all the way down to the
ocean right i'm on the coast so i'm
coming up i'm driving north on the coast
and i can see
constellations and stars
at the horizon
i mean i guess we goosebumps to talk
about it yeah i don't remember if i woke
everybody up or if i even stopped the
car i i just
it was a little bit dangerous i'm you
know i roll down the window to get
better sight and i remember just i kept
turning my head and
i felt connected to something now was i
really connected to something am
imagining it
i don't really care actually i hope it's
true that there's something greater than
just
nature and the material and and
my um
animal self
but there might not be but i do feel it
sometimes and i think most of us have
moments like that
alan lightman the physicist
has a wonderful book on this he's an
atheist
but he talks about lying in a boat
looking up at the stars and how
you feel something and it bothers him as
a physicist and he writes about this
discomfort that he feels something
transcendent there something bigger than
himself so you can feel it out in nature
i have felt it many times
not enough but many times in
random encounters with human beings
under duress i'm sure you have too where
you
you meet someone who's having a very bad
time
and you interact with them in a way that
is not normal you don't usually have
people
sharing incredibly personal things but
they do they need to share it and they
pour out their heart to you and and
you're there for them
and you know one of these moments for me
is this person said you don't want to
hear this do you
and i said no i do
i do and the truth is i didn't want to
hear it but i did i was compelled
literally compelled i wasn't gonna go
anywhere i wasn't gonna
part of me want to run away because it
was so painful it was such a heartache
this person was sharing
somebody i didn't know very well and
those moments those handful of times in
in my life as a human being
where i've encountered another human
being either under duress or in joy it's
also in joy
you know the birth of my children shared
where i wasn't you know privileged to be
in the
in the room with my wife when we when
she said when we gave birth she did most
of the work pretty sure
when she gave birth those moments are
not just like oh that was really fun
even more trivial ones you know
great great musical performances
you know i've written about this um
you know watching next to normal and i
think her name is rachel bay jones
pour out her self in front of
2 000 strangers
and expose herself emotionally
as the character in that play and do it
in a way that isn't just like i'm
actually you don't feel like she's
acting at all you feel like she's
sharing a piece of her human giving you
access to something that's in you too
those moments they're
they're transcendent they're part of
something bigger than ourselves so
that's what i think of
with prayer i think a prayer is
accessing those or trying to access
those more frequently
and for me it's tied in with a belief in
god or a hope of god's being there and
listening but i think for non-religious
people there's something there even when
it's not
religious it's spiritual whatever you
want to call it
you